Reporter: The coronavirus has mutated.
Reporter: Some strains
are far more infectious
Reporter: It doesn't
prove that this new strain
is in fact more infectious.
Abby Tang: Hello, fellow skeptics.
It's me, Abby!
There is a lot of information flying
into our eyes and ears
at any given moment.
And it can be hard to tell sometimes
what's true, what's not.
So I grabbed three of the
most common talking points
that you're probably seeing on your feed,
two truths, one lie,
and I did a little digging.
Truth No. 1: It's OK to go outside!
It's really nice out here.
But social distancing
is still the best way
to control the spread.
Both things can be true.
I'm a big fan of this viral blog post
by an immunologist who delightfully puts
all his credentials on the
front page of his blog.
But he's very up front about
not claiming to be an expert,
and some of the work he cites
hasn't been peer reviewed yet,
so I ran it by our senior
health reporter Anna.
She said, "Looks good."
The whole post is a solid read,
but the main takeaway is this:
Successful infection
equals exposure to virus
multiplied by time.
Basically, the more viral
particles you're exposed to
and the longer you're exposed to them,
the more likely you'll be infected.
Sorry about this gross picture!
But this cough can apparently contain
up to 200 million virus particles,
a number that I could not
find in original source for
but shows up everywhere,
so let's take it with a grain of salt.
Point is, if a sick person
coughs right into your face,
breathes, too, but to a lesser degree,
your chances of getting
infected are gonna be high.
Which is why going over
to a friend's house...
not ideal.
But if you just walk by
someone on the sidewalk,
chances are you're gonna be fine,
because you're limiting the amount of time
you're being exposed
and the number of particles
you're being exposed to
by not locking yourself
in a room full of them.
So going outside is super-low risk
as long as you're staying
physically distant.
I think this quote from a
previous Insider article
sums it up perfectly:
Erich Anderer: Outside
is better than inside,
open space is better than closed,
fewer people is better than more people,
and stay away from sick people.
Or, better yet, stay home
if you're not feeling well yourself.
Abby: Thanks, Erich.
Truth No. 2: The virus
that causes COVID-19
is mutating all the time.
It's true that viruses mutate.
Viruses mutate more often
than practically any other organism.
But we shouldn't be treating it as a big,
scary thing, which a lot of places have.
Which is exactly how this
study turned into this,
then had to be corrected into this.
First, it's worth noting that this paper
has not been peer reviewed,
which it does say in
the study, at the top,
in bright yellow, right before saying
it should not be reported in news media
as established information.
But peers have been informally
reviewing it on Twitter,
and at least one epidemiologist, Bill,
thinks the paper itself is fine.
So, based on that, the problem
is in interpreting the data.
The first headline says
that the mutant coronavirus
is more contagious than the original.
But while the mutated strain
of the virus is more prevalent,
we don't know if it was the
mutation that gave it a leg up.
There are other factors,
like the fact that this particular strain
happened to show up on the East Coast,
which responded to the outbreak
more slowly than the West.
And this is something
that happens all the time,
but mutation is not a dirty word.
Bill put it best in his tweet:
"Mutations are what happens
when genomes replicate.
Comes with the territory like
showers with the springtime."
Poetry.
And if you want to know
what mutation actually is,
I made a whole entire video about it
that you can see here.
And now the lie:
COVID-19 only kills older people
and those with preexisting conditions.
Here's why this meme really gets my goat.
The goal seems to be to quell some panic,
but what it really does
is spread misinformation.
As far as we know at this point,
anyone can die from this disease.
Old people, healthy people, children.
Yeah. Unfortunately, there have been
a couple documented cases.
This study is a little on the older side,
but it's still the biggest one we have.
The death rate is absolutely lower
the younger and healthier you are.
But do you want to be one
of the few in that 0.2%,
guy from my Facebook feed?
I'm gonna say no.
As new information comes out
about who this virus is
most dangerous for and why,
the risk by population adjusts.
Which is a really complicated topic,
so if you want to learn more about it,
my colleague did a video here.
But new information only
changes what we know about risk;
it doesn't eliminate it.
And, yeah, I don't want to die from this,
but I don't want to be sick either.
This CDC data suggests that 30% of cases
and 20% of hospitalizations in the US
are people between the ages of 20 and 44.
And recovery can be a
slow and painful process
that could take months.
Bottom line: Low risk
doesn't mean no risk.
So protect yourself and
the people around you
by being cautious.
Not panicky, but cautious.
So there you go: two truths and a lie.
Add them to your Hinge profile.
And if any of this sets off
your this-is-complete-crap-ometer, great!
Stay skeptical.
Fact-check me; my sources
are in the credits.